we're talking about chimps we're talking
about violence my now friend mr joe
rogan
is a big fan of those things i'm a big
fan of these topics i think a lot of
people
are fascinated by these topics so as
you're saying
why
do we
find the exploration of violence and the
relations between chimps so interesting
what can they teach us about ourselves
until we had this information about
chimpanzees
it was possible to believe
that
uh the
psychology
behind warfare
was
totally the result of some kind of um
cultural recent cultural innovation
right that had nothing to do with our
biology
or if you like that it's got something
to do with uh
sin and
garden
the devil and that sort of thing
but what the chimps tell us
after we
think carefully about it
is that
it seems undoubtedly the case that
our evolutionary psychology
has
given us
the same
kind of attitude towards violence as
has occurred in chimpanzees
and in both species
it has evolved because of its
evolutionary significance in other words
because it's been helpful to the
individuals who have practiced it
and
now we know that
as i mentioned other species do this as
well
in fact you know wolves
um
which this is this is a really kind of
ironical observation
uh conrad lawrence who i mentioned had
been the person who thought that
human
aggression
in the form of killing members of our
own species was unique to our species he
was a great fan of wolves he studied
wolves and in captivity he noted that
wolves are very unlikely to harm each
other in
spats
among members of the same group
what happens is that one of them will
roll over and present their neck much as
you see in a dog park nowadays and and
the other
might put their jaws on the neck but
will not bite
okay so now it turns out that if you
studied wolves in the wild
then neighboring packs often go hunting
for each other
they are in fierce competition
and
as much as 50 percent of the mortality
of wolves is due to being killed by
other wolves
adult mortality wow so it's a really
serious business
the chimpanzees and humans uh fit into a
larger pattern of understanding animals
in which
you don't have an instinct for violence
what you have is an instinct if you like
to use violence adaptively
and if the right circumstances come up
it'll be adaptive if the right
circumstances don't come up it won't be
so some chimpanzee communities are much
more violent than others because of
things like
the frequency with which a large party
of males is likely to meet us a lone
victim and that's going to depend on the
local ecology
but you know so the overall
answer to the question of what do chimps
teach us is that we have to take very
seriously
the notion that in humans
the tendency to
make war
is a consequence of
a long-term evolutionary adaptation and
not just a military ideology or some you
know sort of local patriarchal
phenomenon um and of course you know his
a reading of history a judicious reading
of history
fits that very easily because
war is so commonplace
you